hello YouTube Chancellor's in our
friends this is guns in here welcome to
the 6th part of the dirty chest tricks
after the movie for ePHI and Knight to
f3 the most classical reply from the
black perspective is the move Knight to
c6 and against this setup I'm going to
suggest my own trickier prota which you
are going to use against the right
opponent at the right time so not only
to surprise him but to get the win very
very quickly here I propose you should
play the move Bishop to c4 and more or
less black has two good options that is
Knight to f6 and Bishop to c5
in this video we are going to see Knight
to f6 after Knight to f6 the usual
response from the white perspective is
the move Knight to g5 which is known as
a fried liver attack but when that plays
this way he is very much prepared
against this attack so I'm not going to
recommend in this video instead of that
I'm going to recommend that if you start
with the aggressive move d4 and this is
the starting point of the maxilla attack
as you can see I have highlighted by the
arrows black has few options so as usual
let's look at the worst one first if
Knight captures d4 then white has this
veering sequence start with the move
Bishop captures f7 and after King
captures f7 Knight captures efore check
wherever the King moves right we'll
simply take this Knight and remain a
clear pond up where black King has lost
the castle ride the second move is
Knight captures efore but after this
white can simply capture this pawn and
now black is having a huge difficulty
based on the fact that what is
threatening not only Bishop captures f7
but Queen two defies already in the
where so for example in one quick game
my opponent foolishly played the move
Bishop to c5 but after Queen to defy
there's a threat of capturing the night
and
checkmating black on f7 and please note
that Bishop captures f2 doesn't change
the scenario because white can simply
play the MOOC in to have fun and the
threat remain as it is so black is
definitely going to lose one piece so
that conclude that at this point Black
has the only good reply and that is the
move he captures default after this once
you continue with the fast development
and accordingly where it should Castle
on the kingside and once again black has
two options Knight captures efore I'm
going to cover in the next video so in
this lecture we are going to concentrate
on the move Bishop to c5 which looks
very logical because not only black is
protecting this pawn but black is just
one move away from the castling on the
Kings side and now we are entering in
the max length attack proper here white
will start the attack with the movie
file so you can see that pawn is hitting
the knight and believe it or not black
doesn't have any time to move the knight
let's see some of the examples in one
game my opponent tried to move Knight to
e4 here I continue with attacking that
night with the move Luke - even so my
opponent very naturally defended they
died with the move d5 but here I just
grabbed the pawn and once again hitting
the night
now if
black plays over here Bishop to a5 then
after recapture c7 and Queen captures c7
Knight to d2 will lap the piece so
considering that my opponent here plays
the move f5 which at first sight looks
very good because it's protecting the
knight but after the following sequence
that is d capture c7 and Queen captures
c7 and night to d2 my opponent find out
to his horror that he cannot castle on
the King side so he desperately tried to
save the e-file why the move Bishop to
e7 but here I continued with the move
Knight captures night and after pawn
recaptured I just grabbed the pole with
the movie for hear my opponent played
the move Bishop to f5 and at first sight
it looks like black is all fine because
not only black is hitting the roof but
lacking is one move away from the castle
on the Queen side but here comes the
winning blow and my opponent completely
overlooked this move and that is the
move Knight to g5 BAM
after a long thinking my opponent
realized that how stronger this movies
for example if black castle at this
point then after Bishop to b6
white will gain at least an exchange so
for example if the King moves in the
bishop drops and if the bishop takes
bishop then after Knight captures a six
what will be a clear exchanger so seeing
that my opponent decided to capture the
rook but this leads to amazing
checkmating sequence here I continue
with the Bishop check and please note
the King cannot go through the f8 or d8
square because of the knight folk so my
opponent played the MU King to d7
but after Queen to g4 black King doesn't
survive longer once again if the King
goes to the d8 then Knight to e6 is
exceptionally strong so my opponent
plays the move Queen to d6 but this
leads to the instant disaster and if you
want you can pause the video there is a
checkmate in two so I'm showing you
right now so it started with the move
Knight captures efore and after King to
e5 and queen to e6 as a checkmate
now same can be said if you open and
play the move Knight to g4 because after
this white will continue with the move
Bishop to f4 and if black castle on the
Kings side at this point then after the
simple move s3 Black Knight has the only
square left that is at six and white
will simply capture this Knight and
giving black shattered pawns so that is
more than enough compensation also white
can start his attack by the move c3 so
all in all it's a wonderful position for
white so considering all this we can
easily conclude that at this point black
has the only good move and that is the
move defy a counter-attack to the white
bishop here why should continue with the
move he captures f6 and after D captures
c4 f captures g7 is not strong because
black hasn't committed kingside castling
so instead of that why should first of
all give this Shaq and king to f8 looks
pathetic so the only good reply looks
like Bishop to e6 and here white has
once again exceptionally strong move
Knight to g5
and you can see I have highlighted
boleros black has many options but
amongst them there is only one move that
is right so let's see each moves by ton
the first obvious looking move is Queen
captures f6 and at first sight black
position looks so good except one move
which will ruin the whole structure of
the black and that is the move Knight
kept c6
F captures c6 is pretty much force and
after this why it has this little Queen
check which will NAB the piece of the
black now same can be said if your
opponent plays moves such as G captures
f6
once again if I can capture this bishop
and give this check and remain a bishop
up and the third option which is very
much similar and that is Queen to d7
more or less same story because what is
going to capture this Bishop and after F
captures we have the screen check
so three moves has been dismissed let's
look at rest of the moose
the fourth mover black and tries
castling on the kingside afterwards
white will simply play the move F
captures g7 which will attack the rook
now black has two choices if King
captures g7 then
can you find our missing mu over here
you can pause the video and you can find
it I'm showing you the amazing move and
that is the move rook captures c6 BAM
why is a clear piece up because now
black cannot capture the rook if black
captures the rook then Knight captures
c6 is a super real folk amazing looking
piece right
at this position if the rook moves for
example rook to e8 then Queen to h5
threatening to checkmate black on that
seven
and unfortunately Bishop f5 doesn't walk
over here because white is going to
checkmate anyways to the black King on
the f7 square so that means Castle is
prohibited at this point the rest two
moves left our Queen to d6 and Queen to
defy let's look at Queen to b6 after
Queen to d6
why should continue with the move my to
e4 so hitting the Queen hitting the
bishop and once again black has few
choices if the Queen goes to the effort
square then after F captures g7
black it's simply losing a piece because
after Queen to g7 nightcap to c5 and
white is a clear piece up if the Queen
goes to the D Phi square then white has
this amazing shot that is f captures g7
and black cannot move the rook because
if the rook to g8 that once again we
have the Royal fork on the f6 square the
third who is Queen to e5 but that is
going to a transposition from Queen to
defy variation so let's look at the
final move that is Queen to defy after
Queen to defy White has once again a
very strong move and that is the move
Knight to c3 and at first sight looks
like white has blundered but actually
it's not because if pawn captures night
then white can simply capture the Queen
as that Bishop is pin
so that means that night is untaken if
Queen goes to the d6 or the d7 square
then we already seen the consequences so
the only move left is Queen to F I'm
after Queen to fi it looks like black
has survived from all the attack also
White Knight is hanging so where your
vase is white has to move that night to
the e4 square which will allow black to
castle on the Queen side but before we
look at the castle there is a one more I
like to mention that is G captures f6
which has been played in one of my game
against this I continue with the move G
for hitting the Queen and Queen has to
stay in touch with the bishop because if
the Queen goes to the g6 then after
Knight captures e6 and pawn captures e6
white we'll simply a piece up after
Knight capture C file instead of Queen
to g6 if Queen goes to the e5 square
then after very simple Knight to f3 that
Queen a strap the only square left is
defy afterwards we have this queen and a
king fork
so back to our business the main move is
castling on the queenside and if you
carefully look at this position black
has survived from all the attack and why
doesn't have any attack to speak off but
the perception can be deceptive here the
fun start with the MU g4 so once again
hitting the Queen we already look at
what happened after Queen to g6
so that means Queen has three
possibilities left if Queen captures g4
then after very simple Queen captures
Queen and Bishop captures Queen White
has this lethal move that is Knight
captures f7 so not only [ __ ] two
rooks but White Knight is also attacking
the bishop so it's almost winning
position for white the second obvious
looking move is Queen to defy and I must
tell you that I have raised this
position many many times and many of my
opponent has fallen to the wonderful
traps exist in this situation so let's
see them after Queen to defy why should
continue with the move F captures g7 so
this is the right time to capture this
pawn and the obvious looking more is
rook to g8 afterwards the white should
continue with the move Knight to f6
so for king queen and a rook
the most important factor is queen has
the only one square left that is the d6
square now here what can take the rook
and remain exchanged up but please
remember white king position is open so
white need to be very very careful so
accordingly
what should play the aggressive looking
move Knight G to e4 so you can see now
the queen is in big big trouble and
Queen has the only two square left that
is e 7 + e5 and let's see the
consequences of each square so first is
Queen to e7 after Queen to e7 why it
should certainly capture this rook and
then black capture the night white has
this move Bishop to g5 which indeed turn
out that what will be the whole rook up
the second move is Queen to e5
after this White has this super
aggressive move that is the move fo so
that means the queen is strapped and it
has no mood to go so black has to
forcefully play the move d3 which has a
discover check to the white king and
here white will play King to h1 and now
the idea of d3 is to give a space to the
black Queen she is going to come to the
d4 square and at first sight it looks so
impressive about black but believe it or
not just one move and black and resign
and that is the move
c3 boom the whole queen is gone no space
so those are some of the wonderful traps
exist in this max Lang attack I hope you
enjoy all of them there is a third
alternative for black that is the move
Queen to e5 which you need to do some
research on this but there is one last
trick I want to show you that if you are
playing with an high rated opponent and
you get this position at least you can
force a draw out of this position the
sequence start with the move Knight to
f3 so once again Queen has the only
space to go
that is the d5 and after F captures g7
and rope to g8 if I can do this
perpetual Knight moves that is Knight to
f6
so Queen has to move to the d6 and after
Knight to e4 we can repeat the moves and
get the trough
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like and comment this video
and I'll meet you in my next lecture
that is the morphe attack bye